seeing bitcoin now reclaim that 200 week
moving average just last week was the
second week in a row that it's closed
above it is a sign that we may be
getting more bullish heading above those
ultimate lows so if there was increasing
macro headwinds that drove the whole
market down if equity has reached new
lows i don't think crypto will be spared
that you know ultimate low looks around
the 13 to 14k range but at least crypto
specific things are looking a lot
healthier now than they were the past
three months and it seems like that
overall contagion has now been contained
to some extent which has really allowed
the market to settle here people are
less worried about the next student drop
and more thinking about that overall
macro context that i mentioned at the
beginning all right guys bang bang i've
got frank here with me frank super
excited to break this down arc invest is
now putting out uh the bitcoin monthly
and i figured a great place to start
would be with the analysis on the macro
environment it feels like the backdrop
is really important uh and increasing in
importance uh for bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies uh where's kind of the
best place to start inside of macro that
really captures your attention over the
last month or so
yeah thanks for having me uh super
excited to talk about this report
something we've been working on for the
past you know six to 12 months you know
internally and it's finally another
point we're ready to bring it externally
and kind of show the world how we view
the markets um and this report you know
on a monthly basis summarizes that up
really well um from the macro i think
macro is interesting to set the stage
because it's really what everybody's
watching across all asset classes not
just crypto and you kind of need to
understand where that's headed uh and
where it's been uh to put crypto in
context and some of the things we're
looking at in the on-chain world um you
know crypto specific sentiment
um i think the one of the biggest
driving factors has been sentiment
around the fed and the rate hikes that
have been going on and
the expectation of those rate hikes
going into the future uh jerome powell's
been extremely hawkish over the past six
months before inflation at record highs
uh we're exceeding that narrative start
to change uh just very slightly at the
margin where in his most recent comments
he's indicating that if the macro
economic indicators start to decline the
fed's willing to change their tone and
uh ease on those rate hikes um as rates
have been hiking as anticipation for
rates hiking all asset classes have sold
off and crypto is definitely not
excluded from that um you know crypto's
been trading at a high higher than
normal correlation to equities uh really
since the beginning of covet uh and so
as you know anything that gets affected
by a discount rate especially high
growth tech stock sell-off bitcoin
obviously sold off a lot as well uh
crypto specific contagion tangled in
there that really amplified it
um but as those
overarching macro narratives start to
change
as the anticipation for red rate hikes
at the feds start to slow uh we're
seeing kind of asset classes equities
stabilize crypto stabilize with it
so a good example of that is the
prediction for rate pikes one year out
from the fed that we talked about in the
report uh this is based on the survey of
members of the fed where they think the
rate hikes will be in one year and if
you look back just one month the
probability that rate heights were
rate hikes were going to take us to a
high rate of 350 uh basis points or
above was it 95
that's come down now based on some of
the things we're seeing in the economy
down to below five percent so the
dramatic change in where we think rates
are going to head and
there's a few leading indicators and a
few lagging indicators that lead to that
you can look at the prices of gold and
copper that have significantly sold off
copper especially
which is really an indicator for where
the economy is heading uh if you look
historically and then gold as well as an
inflation hedge typically tends to
perform better uh when the anticipation
for inflation is high gold price has
been coming down indicating that we
think the market thinks that inflation
may be coming down in the long run as
well
um i think the fed if you listen to
their
commentary is very focused on employment
and seeing employment numbers the jobs
report came in very hot last week
you know after the close of the month of
july uh is throwing some confusion
because if you look at the
initial jobless claims or a few other
indicators they're starting to see
employment start to turn down in the
crypto market we've obviously seen a lot
of
uh layoffs you know for everybody
coinbase blockchain.com uh every crypto
lending player uh they're all affected
by this the broader market is as well
especially in kind of you know more
consumer spending uh sensitive areas
um so as these things start to
kind of cool off uh bad for the economy
i mean we've seen two two consecutive
quarters of negative gdp growth um
technically a recession by most people's
definition but that's apparently up for
debate these days
um
and
uh you know indicators that things are
turning down to the point where the fed
may change their tone uh turn more
dovish less hawkish um and that's been
good for both equities and crypto just
over the past i would say three weeks so
in the report you guys specifically
mentioned the fact that the two
consecutive negative gdp quarters uh
could cause some sort of fed pivot
or at least you know change people's
minds talk a little bit more about how
important uh kind of the technical
definition of the recession is versus
maybe uh some of the other metrics or
things like the nber and kind of their
uh you know in some way uh officially
unofficial uh uh labeling of is it a
recession or is it not like how do you
guys you know kind of put weight on the
technical uh two consecutive quarters
versus maybe some of the other metrics
yeah i think for us i mean we look at it
definitionally as two quarters of
negative gdp growth as a recession um
we've been thinking we've been in a
recession we're headed for one for a
long time um and so for for our
perspective we think we're now you know
by definition in a recession um there's
a lot of things out there that impact
who wants there to be a recession or not
um
if you look at you know we're in an
election year it's not good to be the
the economic leader or the political
leader uh in a recession so that's
that's weighing on it a bit as well um
but you know
overall if you look at consumer
sentiment is at lowe's you know since as
far back as the metric goes back to uh
the 70s uh the consumer feels like we're
in a recession and we're starting to see
kind of some of the the earnings reports
come out that indicate that is slowing
uh interestingly there's this feeling of
a very bad sentiment but at the same
time banks report strong consumer
spending so we maybe we feel worse than
we're acting which is kind of an
interesting
counter narrative there
and obviously we've seen the inflation
reduction act and a number of other kind
of government uh proposed solutions
whether they end up being successful or
not is up for debate uh but it does feel
like uh given that
inflation is so high and there's this
technical definition of a recession uh
policy makers uh central bankers they
feel like they have to do something
right it's almost like as humans if
we're doing nothing then we're not in
control is that kind of how you guys
view it as well of you can debate what
is being done but pretty much they're
gonna do something because that's where
they they feel like they've got some
level of uh
of uh control and levers to pull on the
economy
yeah that's exactly right um i mean the
fed's entire job is to control inflation
and so when inflation is high they feel
they need to act and they feel they need
to act strong enough to i think they
think they need to you know declare
victory and they're not going to declare
victory until they see inflation coming
down and those employment numbers
especially uh coming down as well um
that seems like what they've been
indicating the question is do they go
too far and have what they call a hard
landing where they impact the economy
more adversely than needed to cool down
inflation uh it seems and we mentioned
this in the report as well they they may
be willing to overstep a little bit
raise rates a little bit too high cause
a harder landing and really be able to
declare victory on inflation rather than
take some of the leading indicators as
hey we're going there we can ease off
right now
um i think they're more in the former
camp than the latter but we'll see kind
of i think the next two fed meetings um
that
gradually start to change um just based
on kind of you know the last meeting
they said they're willing to consider it
uh for the first time which is kind of
that first step yeah it makes sense
let's jump to bitcoin uh in the report
you all uh really highlight kind of the
first thing is that bitcoin has retaken
uh that 200 average talk a little bit of
as to why this average is so important
uh and and then what is really driving
kind of the retaking of it and does that
mean that maybe the bear market has
actually bottomed
yeah we look at the 200-week moving
average as an important indicator um
just to put in perspective the market
activity um how big the drawdown is that
we've seen versus past cycles and if you
look uh the 200-week moving average
bitcoin's only touched it seven times in
its history and it touched it uh when it
broke below 22 000 uh earlier this month
and
uh historically that's been a good time
to average into bitcoin uh not a
recommendation to buy seller hold
anything but um
the average returns of bitcoin 12 months
out after reaching the 200 week moving
average is over 200 percent so
historically it's been a good indicator
of capitulation and a bottoming event
though not necessarily predicting or
indicating the exact bottom because we
see times where bitcoin's price drops
dramatically uh quickly below and then
and then recovers um uh sometime after
um so it's kind of just a global signal
that we're we're close to a bottom
though you need to look at the more
specific on-chain indicators to see uh
where that bottom might actually occur
um so so seeing uh bitcoin now reclaim
that 200 week moving average just last
week was the second week in a row that
it's closed above it uh is a sign that
we may be more getting more bullish
heading above those uh those ultimate
lows um i think it's still important to
put
this drawdown uh in context to previous
drawdowns so bitcoin uh bitcoin in
general for global bottoms has typically
bottoms below 80 drawdown from all-time
highs
covid was one exception where the
drawdown was very quick and there was
the v-shaped recovery in pretty much all
assets uh where it didn't this time as
well we didn't get down to those 80
levels um so if there was say um you
know increasing macro headwinds that
drove the whole market down if equity
has reached new lows i don't think
crypto will be spared uh that you know
ultimate low looks around the 13 to 14k
range um so we're not ruling that out as
a possibility um but at least crypto
specific uh things are looking a lot
healthier now
than they were uh say the past three
months um and i think you know just to
put in context what's happened that's
driven a lot of this chaos in the market
really starting back in may with the
collapse of uh the terra and the uh ust
stable coin
that was a like a 50 billion dollar
event if you look at the 20 million
market cap of you have 20 billion market
cap of ust and the 30 billion market cap
of luna that really evaporated overnight
uh and also had bitcoin specific selling
pressure in there because the um
the luna foundation guard was buying
bitcoin to backstop that peg which
obviously didn't work um but that was a
massive selling event the markets all
sold off from it uh and then over june
and july we saw the contagion of that
event uh start to show itself in the
market um we we had a strong feeling
there would be some we didn't know
exactly who would be affected uh two of
the main ones that turned out to be
celsius and three euros capital um
celsius they both had exposure to terra
um three arrows taking a bit
on that ecosystem took a big hit to
their balance sheet that rendered them
unable to weather two other trades that
they made that also went bad
uh one of those was the great scale
bitcoin trust um
as that discount widened their trade uh
move against them and then also the uh
lido's liquid state ether uh that they
had a large position in as well was also
trading at a discount uh these two
products trading below spot um
essentially uh put them under water in a
way that um rendered them unable to meet
um
their uh margin calls uh which it also
turns out they were borrowing for pretty
much everybody in crypto um so that
we learned kind of throughout the entire
month more and more about that story
three arrows you know at their peak was
managing between 10 and 18 billion
dollars uh so we went from a 50 50
billion dollar accident in tara you know
10 to 18 in uh three euros capital
celsius as well which halted um
withdrawals in their platform ultimately
filed for bankruptcy in the beginning
part of this month they were managing
over 28 billion at one point
um the the
tail has been getting longer in terms of
who's been
halting withdrawals filing for
bankruptcy uh but the the actual
magnitude of those events if you look at
you know even another lender uh
haldelnot which i hadn't heard of before
but paused withdrawals this morning uh
much smaller in magnitude and it seems
like that overall contagion has now been
contained to some extent which has
really allowed the market to settle here
uh people are less worried about the
next student drop and more kind of
thinking about that overall macro
context that i mentioned at the
beginning given kind of uh that storm if
you will uh in the report you all uh
identified that bitcoin is stabilizing
and you kind of break down bitcoin
across a number of different aspects uh
you start off with the network and
specifically break it down to network
security and network usage uh it appears
that you all are neutral on the network
security kind of change month over month
but you're bullish on network usage
maybe give us a little bit more color
there as to kind of how you arrive at
neutral versus bullish and why you guys
are excited about the network usage
specifically this episode is brought to
you by eight sleep good sleep is a game
changer and the eight sleep pod is the
best sleep machine i sleep on it every
single night a great night of sleep
allows you to be healthier be more
arrested and have more energy throughout
the day and on the brand new eight sleep
pod three you can sleep as cold as 55
degrees fahrenheit or as hot as 110
degrees fahrenheit that's the secret of
thermoregulation better sleep better
energy get yourself innate sleep you can
go to eightsleep.com pomp today to go
ahead and get 150 off your order
aidsleep.com not only do i sleep on it
every night it literally changed my life
and i begged the founders to let me
invest in the company eightsleep.com
go get yourself an eight-sleep pod and
get a better night of sleep
yeah so i think uh honestly aspect uh
one of the entities in the network
that's most affected by price drawdowns
is miners and we've seen
um
many of the publicly traded mining
companies uh sell off bitcoin uh from
their balance sheet which they had been
holding
during the month
um to pay down uh loans basically meet
their obligations of operations mining
revenue is down uh 45 from where it was
year on year um so it's not easy to be a
minor in this environment especially
with long-term purchase agreements plans
to expand um
expand capacity
uh so that leaves us and hash rate as
well has come down a bit um partially
driven by the sell-off uh miners going
offline
uh that leaves us neutral uh it's not a
massive capitulation in half straight
like you saw with the china
ban of mining which
uh in terms of uh absolute security uh
was a negative in the short term uh but
in the long term led to a broader
decentralization of the hashrate base
that i think was very positive for the
network
um that would have been something that
short term would be negative um here
we're relatively neutral with that um in
terms of uh
usage of the network if you look at the
active entities uh though they always
kind of peak during
market tops
you have kind of new entrants coming in
that are excited and you know frankly
speculating on the asset
uh you have this kind of long-term
channel of growing active entities that
the market lows uh that's positive to
see being maintained here as well as
usage on the lightning network
increasing as well i think the lightning
network's really interesting and that we
typically see usage accelerate during uh
bear markets
and i think there's there's multiple
things at play here
one is that uh the builders in the space
that are really dedicated to the network
they can stop worrying about price and
speculation and the new highs in the
market and it can actually get to
building and shipping new products
uh that's a really healthy sign and
seeing lightning network liquidity reach
new highs even though the market reached
price uh uh you know local lows
uh i think it's healthy and then also i
think the second thing that impacts us a
bit is that
there's some amount of lag between
markets peaking and every company wants
to get in and build on top of bitcoin
and lightning specifically you had
announcements from square and robin hood
back in in february and march around the
lightning network uh those are
announcements then you know take time to
build out and launch and so i think
there's some amount of lag of lightning
network reaching uh greater capacity
after market highs as those products
that are kind of thought about in the
bull markets get developed and built in
the bear markets
yeah it makes a lot of sense that uh
kind of the good times bring a lot more
capital investment because it's just
more capital to kind of go around but it
takes time to actually build out some of
that infrastructure the same thing
is true around holder behavior as well
you kind of get tons and tons of people
who pile in if you will at the top or
kind of at elevated price levels it's a
thing where as price of financial assets
go up people get more excited and want
to buy it but when they go down maybe
they're not as excited you don't see as
many people coming in and kind of buying
discounted asset prices in the report
you all break down this holder behavior
and it seems like you are net bullish
talk us through a little bit as to how
you evaluate holder behavior and arrive
at netbullish
yeah so i think it's important to look
at
how much of the activity in the network
where supply is shifting from kind of
these short-term speculative holders to
long-term holders that are gonna
be supporters of the network in the long
run and aren't just here for that kind
of speculative trade and as you see
markets kind of reaching tops you'll see
that short-term holder base really grow
in terms percent of total supply we
define uh we use glass node's definition
of a of a long-term or short-term holder
which cuts off at 155 days so you hold
coins in your wallet and you haven't
moved them for 155 days basically that
level hits you into the long-term holder
bucket and during this bear market we've
seen long-term holders accumulating
supply so just over the past year for
example plus six percent uh on the
long-term holder supply base uh that
generally means that
um there's a stable cost basis
establishing
less speculation the more market
more long-term supporters of the network
interestingly similar metric is also
locked supply which uses a different uh
heuristic to get the same kind of notion
of this long-term holder versus the
short-term speculative holder uh which
uses a
a
probability that class node has uh come
up with to identify the probability that
a supply a token will move out of a
wallet and so how much supply is locked
in this kind of more illiquid wallets uh
that are more likely to be long-term
holders versus uh illiquid wallets and
that's on the rise as well
overall making us not bullish
and then when you look at long term and
short term valuation uh you all are
neutral uh in both long and short term
explain a little bit as to how you break
this down
yep so i think the uh the this concept
of the the market's cost basis or the
realized price is really important here
uh so the the realized price is
the aggregate cost basis of the market
if you looked at the price that every
coin was last transferred at
and that gives you a sense of the the
overall kind of cost basis of investors
and when the the market cap or the
individual price per bitcoin drops below
that realized price of that cost basis
the market's net underwater uh coins are
trading below where the
market last priced them at when they
moved and we saw during uh during this
cycle bitcoin's price dropped below that
cost basis typically another indicator
of that kind of bottoming of that it's
not the ultimate bottom there's other
cost bases that we look at to see where
a more accurate signal of the kind of ex
what might be the exact bottom uh but
overall breaching that market cost basis
and then now just uh beginning of this
month and end of july getting back above
it uh typically a bullish sign
uh in terms of percent supply and profit
this is less looking in aggregate of
pricing all the assets at uh where they
last moved in the current market price
and instead looking at individual
positions and how much of the supply of
bitcoin uh is in profit and so coins
that were last moved a long time ago say
in the previous bare site uh bowl cycle
orbiter cycle uh there's still a good
amount of profit in that system uh
overall and so that's what leaves us
kind of neutral there
and then i want to jump to this idea of
bitcoin and the investor cost basis uh
there what we've seen in the 2018 bear
market is that uh bitcoin kind of fell
completely to this idea of this like
delta cost basis but in 2020 and so far
in the in the current bear market we
have not seen that it kind of just
dropped and bounced off of the investor
cost basis describe a little bit uh the
variations or differences between kind
of investor cost bases and this delta
cost basis and then why you think that
in some cases we kind of fall completely
versus maybe it's just bouncing off of
investor cost basis
yeah i think this is this is probably
one of my favorite charts of the report
this month uh the the market cost basis
is the green line on this chart is kind
of what i just identified um as this
realized price over time uh the the
price the coins last moved at
essentially in aggregate uh the investor
cost basis takes a similar methodology
but subtracts out coins that were mined
um newly behind coins or the value of
newly mined coins and so the idea is to
take kind of the the aggregate cost
basis but subtract out the cost basis of
of miners specifically which if you take
the market and you take out miners what
you have left is investors and that's
the origin of this investor cost basis
and this is a metric that uh we actually
originated at arc uh through work but
done by yasin and david our other crypto
analysts uh to come up with this and it
relies on uh that latter half of the
metric the minor cost basis um in the
on-chain world is called thermo-cap a
metric coin by nick carter and so this
gives you a sense of the the cost basis
uh overall then segmented down by miners
versus investors and so seeing where the
market price bottoms relative to
investors gives us some sense of the the
severity of the drawdown and this has
been hit
in all the major uh bear market bottoms
uh including the coveted bottom uh in
2020 the next level down below that is
something called the delta cost basis
that was actually also invented by david
well on our team
that gives you
a more accurate signal for a very very
severe market bottom that we've seen in
2018 and 2015 and 2012 for example
that takes that top-line market cost
basis and subtracts the average price of
the of bitcoin over its history this
average cap concept and so this kind of
combining a a fundamental metric that
uses on-chain analysis with a technical
metric that uses price
uh which is an interesting combination
but it gives you the sense for or this
bottoming level for very severe
correction and that's what we saw in
2018 and what we actually didn't see in
2020 kind of that v-shaped recovery and
that very quick bounce after uh the
world started to understand the the
potential impacts for uh the kovic
pandemic that resulted in us not kind of
going all the way down to that level if
we look at the the current
uh environment uh in july of 2022 the
bitcoin's price breached below market
cost and it just barely dipped below the
investor cost basis but it didn't go all
the way down to the delta cost basis uh
which kind of um
it correlates to the the idea that price
sold off
uh severely but not as severe as it has
in other capitulation events uh like
2018 when bitcoin sold off uh down to
down to uh below uh that uh delta cost
basis
um so when we look at this one the fact
that uh bitcoins to price has reclaimed
the investor cost basis and the market
cost basis as a signal of a bullish turn
in the market but also still caution
that uh until a few more indicators tip
uh you can't rule out
a drop down to the delta cost basis
which would again be around that 14k
level
um the
um
yeah so we're we're kind of weighing
those two
yeah one of the pieces uh is you follow
up um kind of that analysis by saying
hey look there could be more downside we
talked earlier about uh kind of 85
percent being a a line or more than 80
percent uh in some of the early bear
markets all the way through 2018 but
then in the 2020 kind of covid pull down
we didn't get there uh in the summer of
2021. uh again we had a big drop of like
50 but we didn't actually get the full
80. uh and right now we've been sitting
around 70 or so uh and so is there a
thought process or an argument where
you could make hey there's just stronger
holders and so naturally there should be
less and less volatility over time uh
and a more kind of distributed holder
base
dampens that volatility and so like this
would be a natural progression or is
that you know kind of bag holder quotes
and people are super excited to make
that argument but uh maybe the data
tells us something different
yeah i think it's i think it's
definitely dangerous to say that uh you
know the network's more adopted so we'll
never reach lower lows
that obviously could happen but i think
overall there is truth to it
um there is a more distributed holder
base and
crypto now is seen um is more
legitimized as an independent asset
class um i think
that's one of the big things that's
changed in this cycle versus previous
cycles is nobody's um
nobody knows about the space is saying
oh crypto's gonna totally go away now
they're saying crypto's here how are we
gonna deal with it uh and i think that's
a big change that that uh contributes to
this quite a bit
and if we then look at ethereum uh you
all included that as well so you could
have macro you have bitcoin and then you
have ethereum talk a little bit maybe
just about how you at arc are looking at
bitcoin and ethereum are they
competitive are they two different
assets just you know even before you dig
into the network fundamentals what is
going on with uh with the two different
assets and the way you all look at them
as either technologies or as investment
opportunities this episode is brought to
you by ledger the best crypto hardware
wallet everyone's heard the phrase not
your keys not your coins and that's more
true today than it's ever been
ultimately a value proposition of
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies is
self-custody where you get to retain
ownership over your digital assets that
is what ledger specializes in they've
got multiple pieces of hardware and they
also have the ledger live mobile app
which makes it seamless to not only
retain control over your bitcoin but
also allows you to interface with
exchanges lending platforms and other
types of software products if you're
interested in upping your self-custody
game go check out ledger today
shop.ledger.com again that's
shop.ledger.com go check them out and
start doing self custody you'll thank me
later
yes so i think this is a really good
point um to highlight yeah before
getting into the charts just how we look
at the market and it's something we've
spent um a long time thinking about
since we since we started researching
crypto back in in 2014 and 2015 uh but
really over this cycle it's gotten
interesting and more important because
the market is bigger than just crypto
currencies now uh and i don't think
they're competing on the same dimensions
uh when we look at the market of public
blockchain innovation we see three kind
of parallel revolutions that are all
happening
uh the the revolution in in monetary
policy this money revolution uh is the
first and probably most profound
application of public blockchain
infrastructure which is really
bitcoin a uh a self-sovereign form of
money
that is displacing government-issued
money uh displacing the fed displacing
uh traditional uh international
settlement rails like fedramp um
or fedwire sorry um the
uh and i think that is is is really
important but if you look at the total
crypto market cap that's not all of the
market cap and especially since 2018
we've seen kind of new uh revolutions
emerge in addition to that monetary
revolution
uh which we kind of classify as this
financial and internet revolution it's
innovations built around smart contracts
like decentralized finance displacing
traditional financial intermediaries
and it's kind of what we've just seen
the fruits of which there's a lot of
speculation around it still but
uh web 3 and the broader kind of
user-owned uh internet displacing
traditional web two intermediaries uh
and we think there's room for all three
revolutions to grow in parallel on the
fundamental basis of public blockchain
infrastructure uh just that there's
gonna be different lanes that they
compete that are important to recognize
and different trade-offs that they have
to make so for example
bitcoin's not trying to
uh
facilitate smart contracts or nfts or
all this kind of like crazy stuff you
see out in the financial internet
revolution
and nor should it because to support
those you need to make sacrifices on the
ultimate level of decentralization the
the solidness and the credible
neutrality of your base layer that
bitcoin is uncompromising on because it
needs to because you can't have a nation
nation-state adopted currency that
undergoes a massive transition like
ethereum is about to
like the merge that can disrupt your
monetary base like when you're thinking
about something at that level you need
this conservative
lane that bitcoin takes now when you
look at those financial and internet
revolutions
you have this more competition on on
technology rather than kind of monetary
soundness and so that's why every
ethereum stellana everything in this
space has to kind of advance and iterate
on its technology and also if you look
at you know some of the more ultra high
throughput low value transactions like
gaming you need to sacrifice that level
of decentralization that you're that you
have in the network
you have solana that cost you know
hundreds of thousands of dollars a year
to run validators on they need to do
that to support what they're trying to
do
bitcoin doesn't need to do that to
support what it's trying to do um and so
we look at the market across those three
lanes and i think that's really
important context for kind of
understanding and dissecting that crypto
market um overall
one of the things that you all point out
initially is the upward trend line of
ethovir btc or kind of the btc trading
pair why is that so important and uh and
then what is the significance of some
sort of uptrend there
yeah so i think this this represents a
few things one over time uh ethe has
thrown in value relative to bitcoin i
think this is uh at least for me this
starts um
after the
2017-2018 market cycle where you saw
this massive speculation in icos which
were this kind of first use case for
smart contracts which is just
crowdfunding hey we can raise a bunch of
money and we'll probably use it to build
stuff in the future that had a massive
hype cycle it was a bunch of money
raised before uh innovation really had
time to take fruits and technology was
actually built that you didn't see
happen until more 2020 that kind of
catalyzed some of the market activity
that we saw over the past two years um
namely around d5
um
seeing kind of the eth btc pair as a
surrogate for the growth and the broader
adoption of crypto which includes those
two other revolutions that financial and
that internet revolution uh that's what
we think is healthy for crypto becoming
bigger overall in the long run and then
on the more shorter term
we typically see in a risk-off
environment this kind of newer frontier
the financial and internet revolution
sell off harder than the the original
kind of profound monetary revolution and
so this pair will typically perform
worse in a risk risk off environment and
conversely perform better in a risk-on
environment and so seeing the each ptc
pair each start to outperform bitcoin in
the month of july uh as as another
signal of this risk-on environment uh
going forward and how much of this is
just people speculating on the merge and
and kind of uh you know by the news uh
or i'm sorry buy the rumor sell the news
uh versus it's signaling something that
is deeper you know kind of more macro
whether it's risk on or uh uh investors
you know they want each not bitcoin or
any of the other narratives that kind of
get pushed by by various communities
yeah there's a lot of narratives out
there um i think if you look at for
example eath compared to other um the
all layer one smart contract space it
has outperformed that as well which
signals that there is some amount of
activity here from the merge uh
anticipation of the merge finally
getting an estimated date you know if
you
i think how i look at this is that it's
almost like a bitcoin happening cycle
where there's all this anticipation and
talk and news buzz leading up to the
event
and then there's like kind of not very
significant price activity uh because
it's all been priced in and the
anticipation uh the real uh effects of
that you kind of see at a lag you know
six plus months after uh we might see
something similar here i think it's
going to be good for the ethereum
community to kind of get this off their
chest something that's been planned
since uh really before if you're in may
not even launched
um
finally getting over with and having
this transition done uh will be good
just from a technical and execution risk
that it's been waiting on the actual
impacts and kind of the this investor
narrative of
an esg friendly move reducing power
consumption is definitely something
we've been vocal that we don't see as a
benefit of this change
we think there's pretty profound aspects
of proof of work that make it ultimately
more decentralized as a base layer uh
consensus mechanism than proof of stake
and are you know hesitant uh to view
this transition positively because of
that
um that's our view probably the minority
of total investors that uh are
interested in ethereum um but overall i
think getting the merge kind of out of
the way will will be um kind of net
bullish yeah uh we are a couple of weeks
away from uh the uh the planned merge do
you think it goes forward uh on that
timeline or do you think there's room
for it to be pushed back again
yeah uh i think
i think they're going to try the
question is does it move forward uh
without hiccups uh they've been doing um
what are called shadow forks as well as
migrating the uh ethereum test nets over
the past few months uh they've been
increasingly more successful so
uncovering less bugs than migrating
larger chestnuts uh the final test net
merge is in the middle of this month
um that'll be the best indicator to see
kind of where they are
but they're still kind of no true analog
to migrating the main network and all
the activity that's built on top of it
um it's often referred to as uh changing
an engine in mid-flight um but based on
how the test net merges have been going
i think it likely will be successful uh
whether they hit that september 19 uh
date that they've talked about i
wouldn't be surprised if it gets pushed
uh but i think that's before the end of
the year
you all call out in the report defy
infrastructure it's basically working
exactly as it's intended during this uh
kind of lending uh and contagion event
over the last couple of weeks in crypto
many of the centralized uh players uh
ended up being affected now not all of
the problems obviously things like terra
luna uh definitely came more from a kind
of a d5 world so so it's not completely
black and white but i think in many
cases uh things that people thought
wouldn't break broke and things that
people thought would break did not break
uh talk a little bit about kind of the
d5 infrastructure and how you all are
are thinking through uh kind of the
robust and resilient aspect uh given
kind of the market stresses in the last
couple weeks
yeah i think this is really interesting
and important for those kind of
financial and internet revolutions going
forward that i mentioned before
um the
when you
you know if you said we'd have a 70
uh drop in market prices who's gonna
who's gonna make it through and what's
gonna break i think d5 is a spot that
people would have pointed to and said
that's definitely going to break
um and what we saw is that the the
centralized intermediaries that may have
been acting in d5 we know celsius was
super heavily uh
they broke because they took outsized
risks beyond what people thought they
were taking uh celsius had a massive
exposure uh to liquid state ether to to
illiquid stake either
positions in d5 loans to three euros
capital kind of all this stuff um
a lot of entities kind of went outside
their normal operating rules so we know
for example genesis uh loaned to three
years capital kind of a sweetheart deal
that required less collateral than they
required from their other um their other
counterparties
and that came back to bite them pretty
hard they basically broke their typical
risk management rules to make a good
deal with a friend
if you look at d5 which is all operating
on smart contracts these are examples of
uh ave and compound the two largest
sunday markets on ethereum
smart contracts can't break their rules
they can be programmed with bad rules
and i think tara is a good example of
that where the the algorithmic
stablecoin design was just not weathered
to to handle a severe market selloff uh
of all crypto assets uh that eventually
led to its unwinding and kind of a death
spiral the whole nine yards
that was uh i would say d5 that was
programmed wrong you see other d5 that's
programmed wrong with all the hacks that
have been happening especially around
smart contract bridges uh between
blockchains uh but the d5 that's been uh
around and managing billions of dollars
of assets for a long time and has really
been tested uh these two lending markets
on ethereum as an example
really did weather the storm quite well
uh no major outages and and no major uh
insolvencies to report and that's
suffering a 77 decline in in total
outstanding debt and a 67 decline in
total deposits so going from 40 billion
in deposits down to below 15 billion uh
since the start of the year is a massive
deleveraging
uh that they handle no problem those
that were over their skis got liquidated
and that's how the protocol is supposed
to function and those who had proper
collateral boosted collateral or paid
back debt as the market sold off were
able to get their positions out uh that
i think is really healthy to see it's
also an indicator just of the the total
leverage that it was in the system that
has now come back dramatically uh
marking kind of relatively healthier uh
leverage environments going forward the
last thing i want to talk about uh is
you've done what i would consider macro
down to the network analysis right you
the the report does a fantastic job of
kind of uh not only breaking down um
kind of the data itself but also arcs
perspective on bitcoin eth and uh and
the macro environment
when you all look out through the rest
of the year are there any kind of
takeaways uh coming out of this report
or any uh kind of expectations things
you're watching milestones potentially
that you think are important for people
to understand
yeah i think um you know now through the
rest of the year in terms of price
action is going to be driven by that
macro component that we talked about um
to to kick this call off
the
uh
the correlation to equities is strong
and
will still have an impact on crypto i
don't think it will be spared if
equities reach new lows um say the the
fed remains extremely hawkish
um and we have a stronger than
anticipated recession uh i don't think
that's gonna be good for crypto
but what's promising is that the fed is
starting to at least starting to
indicate that they could uh um ease up a
bit uh that's important
um seeing kind of equities start to
stabilize is important and then also
seeing um you know the maybe the one
chart we didn't talk about is the
um the bitcoin price activity during
market hours is really being led by the
us uh which has typically uh at least
for the past two years
led bitcoin rallies so when the us is a
buyer especially an environment where
bitcoin is correlated to equities that's
typically a good thing for bitcoin's
price um so we're kind of watching all
these if i had to say an on-chain
indicator that's that's important top of
mind we were talking about it just this
morning um is the sopr the span output
profit ratio um as coins are actively
moving around the network how many of
those are moving at a price above or
below what they last moved at so are
people uh taking losses we're taking
gains and right now it's right about
neutral basically the market's trading
uh people are willing to move coins at
break even uh if people start uh that
could be
an indicator that it's going to be
strong resistance people get out as soon
as they can to break even and the market
sells off more but if that goes above
and the market turns net uh positive on
that metric i think that's another
confirmation point um that the worst is
behind us um so it's a summary of kind
of the major things that we're watching
yeah i think it's fantastic and what i
love about it is there's price there's
network there's kind of you know this
holistic view of the market and of the
assets where can we send people to find
you on the internet frank or find this
report when you release it each month
moving forward
yeah uh you can find me on twitter at
downing arc um the report you can find
it on your scenes twitter you seen our
or the arc and best website
www.arcinvest.com
awesome frank thank you so much for for
taking the time to break down this
report uh we'll definitely do it again
uh kind of each month as you guys
continue to uh put this out and i think
for those that are looking for a kind of
very high signal quick understanding of
what happened in the past month and how
the network itself the assets and the
macro environment are playing out uh
it's a fantastic read so thanks for all
the hard work to put it together and i
suggest other people go subscribe to it
awesome thanks so much for having me